العربيه
وتعظيم
الكشف عن وثائق سريه جديده في منزلي تعود
لفتره عضويته بمجلس الشيوخ وتوليه منصب
نائب الرئيس
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الهمباب من العربيه نبدا النشره من
اوكرانيا
الواقعه غرب مقاطعه دوناتس معارك ساخنه
بين القوه الروسيه والاوكرانيه
الروس سيطروا على الجزء الاكبر من المدينه
لفتح الطريق امام الامدادات العسكريه
الروسيه
فريق العربيه رصد الوضع على خطوط المواجهه
بين الطرفين في مرينكا
توجهنا مع المقاتلين الى مدينه مارينكا
الملتهبه بالمعاركي شمال غربيه
المقاتلين لارض المعركه عبر حاملات الجنود
الذي سيطر عليه الجيش الروسي الهدف هو
الوصول الى فنادق خط المواجهه الاول
هذه اثار المعارك الضاريه والساخنه التي
شهدتها هذه المدينه مدينه مارك خلال
الاشهر الماضيه حيث سيطر الجيش الروسي على
جزء كبير من هذه المدينه الحديث عن ثلثي
المدينه والمتبقي الثلث الاخير وهي
الابنيه الشاهقه سرنا كاسراب النمل حذرين
من الالغام بمحاذاه الجدران خشيه القناصه
في الثلث الاخير من المدينه يشتبك
المقاتلون بالبنادق وضعنا كاميرا على خوذه
مقاتل خلال عمليات الاقتحام التي تهدف
لاكمال السيطره على المدينه
نادي الرساله
بعيد
[موسيقى]
على ضوء شمعه والدبابات تقصف موقعنا عبر
المسيرات
مرت دقائق الليل كالسنين بانتظار بزوق
الفجر على اثير الرشاقات الرصاص والصواريخ
ينفذ الجيش الروسي عمليات اقتحام في مدينه
ماركا الكائنه شمال غرب مقاطعه دانيت
اليوم بالذات القوات الخاصه الروسيه تنفذ
عمليه اقتحام على هذه الابنيه ذات الخمسه
الطوابق نسمع اصوات الاشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه وايضا اصوات القصب
المدفعي والقصد بالدبابات لقناتي العربيه
والحدث رائد الاخضر
ومع تزاوج الضغوط الاوكرانيه والغربيه على
المانيا لتسليم دبابات ليوبار الى الكيف
اعلن وزير الدفاع الالماني بورسعيد انه
سيزور وكيف قريبا لبحثي مساله تسليم تلك
الدبابات وهكذا
ارسالها بالفعل مؤثرا الى انه على حوار
الوثيق مع الحلفاء في النيتو ومع الولايات
المتحده على وجه الخصوص من اجل التوصل الى
اتخاذ قرار بشان عمليه التسليم
وكاله اوكرانيا اعرفت على صفها اذاعه تردد
الدول الغربيه في امدادها بدبابات ثقيله
رغم دفعات الاسلحه الجديده والضخمه التي
اعلنها الحلفاء وفي انتقاد العالم
دول البلطيق برلين على تزويده اوكرانيا
بدبابات اليوبارد اثنان بشكل فوري
السلاح الاكثر جدلا حتى الان بين حلفاء
اوكرانيا في الايام القليله الماضيه هو
الدبابات فالسؤال الذي
هو هل داعم اوكرانيا مستعدون لتزويدها
بالدبابات ليبرتو الالمانيه وابرز
الامريكيه الاكثر تطورا وبعد ساعات من
الجدل قرر المجتمعون الامتناع عن هذه
الخطوه في الوقت الحالي في خطوه غير
مسبوقه على الرغم من مناسبات الرئيس
الاخرانيه
الامر الذي اثار فضول المحللين ودفعهم
للتساؤل اما اذا كانت هذه الدبابات تستحق
الضجه
في موقع 19 للدفاع والامن القومي فان
دبابات ليبرتو
المعنيه لن تغير بالضروره قواعد اللعبه
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا في ساحه القتال خاصه ان
اوكرانيا استلمت بالفعل حزمه ضخمه من
المساعدات العسكريه من الولايات المتحده
وحدها عباره عن 50 مركبه قتال برادلي و90
مركبه قتاليه كم مصفحه من طراز سترايكر
و500 و80 شاحنه مصفحه ام ار اي بي و 350
سياره عسكريه من طراز هانفي ناهيكا عن 60
الف صاروخ والقائمه الطويله تتوسع
الاهم من موضوع الدبابات هو من الذي
سيقودها فما فائده اي دبابه دون سائق مختص
وفقا للموقع الالكتروني اثبتت ام 1 ابرامز
فعاليتها اثناء الغزو الامريكي للعراق فقط
لانها كانت جيده مثل الافراد الذين
يديرونها والذين خضعوا لتدريبات معقده
وطويله بحسب الخبراء فلا يمكن لاي دبابه
ان تكون السبب وراء فوزي اوكرانيا بدون
ذلك
ويخلص موقع 19 ايضا الى ان جميع الدبابات
لها عيوب بقدر ما تتمتع به من امتيازات
فالدبابات الغربيه قد تكون اكثر دقه وتصيب
اهداف ابعد ولكن بالمقابل فان تيز 24
لا تزال تتمتع بقدرات هائله تمنحها القوه
لتدمير دبابات المتطوره بالكامل لذا حتى
لو كانت اوكرانيا تمتلك ليبرتو وابرز فان
ذلك لم يكن ليغير من نتائج معركه خيرسون
على واقع
وزراء ودفاع الناتو اجتمعوا في المانيا
وفشلوا بارسال دبابات ثقيله الى اوكرانيا
اصابع اللون توجهت صوب المانيا التي قيل
انها رفضت ارسال دباباتها ليوبارد 2 الا
اذا قامت امريكا بذلك اولا
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا رات ان ذلك تردد قاتل
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه على تويتر التردد في
هذه المرحله يقتل المزيد من مواطننا
ودعوه لحلفائك الى التفكير بشكل اسرع
[موسيقى]
من جهه اخرى اعرب عن اسفيه لموقف المانيا
الحذر في هذا الشان
البنتاجون انتقادات لاذعه لالمانيا
[موسيقى]
محبطون من موقف المانيا ويبدو انها لا
تعرف الفرق بين دباباتنا ودباباتها
والسيناتور الامريكيه الجمهوريه
واشنطن معا مباشره بعد زيارته لكيف
كتاب المعارك في اوكرانيا اجره روسيا
وتدريبات على نظام دفاعها الجوي في سماء
العاصمه موسكو في خطوه تعدل الاولى منذ
بدايه الحرب فبراير الماضي
لاول مره منذ بدايه الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
روسيا تنفذ تدريبات تحاكي صد هجوم مفترض
على العاصمه موسكو قد يكونوا بالصواريخ او
بغارات تنفذها طائرات او مسيرات غربيه وان
كان بيان الدفاع الروسيه بررها بانها
للتصدي لهجوم مجموعه تخريبيه لعدو وهمي
تكمن اهميه التدريبات في انها تظهر مخاوف
روسيا من تعرض عاصمتها لهجمه مع وصول
اسلحه غربيه متقدمه لاوكرانيا خاصه بعد
تنفيذ هجمات على مناطق حدوديه روسيه مثل
بالجورد وتعرض قواعد عسكريه لهجمات
بمسيرات في عمق الروسي كما حدث في سيرته
وريزان فضلا عن مناطق ذمتها روسيا
كالقرمرم او لنيتها القيامه بعمليه عسكريه
كبيره تخشى ردا غربيه عليها حيث تتوقع
دوائر المخابرات الغربيه قيام روسيا
بعمليه واسعه في اوكرانيا واحتمال دخول
بلاروسيا معها
نشر انظمه دفاع جوي على اسطح ابنيه في
موسكو يراه البعض تناقضا مع التصريحات
الروسيه التي تؤكد ان مسار العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا يسير على ما يرام
وافق قطط وزاره الدفاع اما عن الاسباب
فيرجع مراقبون الامر للتخوف من امتلاك
اوكرانيا مسيرات يصل مداها الى الف كيلو
متر ما يعني وصولها الى العاصمه الروسيه
فيما يرى البعض ان ذلك جزء من الدعايه
الروسيه وذلك عبر اظهار التهديد قد تتعرض
له موسكو لسكان العاصمه وتصوير اوكرانيا
على انها عدو لروسيا ما يزيد التعيييد
الشعبي لما تسميها روسيا عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى زياده
نسبه التطوع في القوات الروسيه هو ذلك هو
حديث عن تعبئه جديده قد تكون غير معلنه
قال بانه لديه امكانيه للوصول نحو 1,000
كم عبر المسيرات التي طورها ولذلك يمكن ان
تصل الى مدينه موسكو لكن كما قلت ربما
تكون روسيا تحضر الراي العام الروسي من
اجل معركه طويله وادعوا دفاعات جويه على
اسطح المنازل في موسكو مشهد قد يكون الاول
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه وهو المشهد
الذي يستحضر تلك الاجواء ويهدد بحرب كبيره
الاكثر من ذلك تدريبات روسيا كانت تهدف
لحمايه منشات عسكريه بدواحي موسكو بنشر
منظومه اس 300 بهدف التصدي لهجوم
بالطائرات والصواريخ البالستيه وهي التي
تملكها حصرا دول النيترو
موسكو سبق وان تعرضت لهجوم في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وتمكن الاتحاد السوفيتي
من وقف تقدم دبابات هتلر نحو المدينه
حينها فهل نحن امام تصعيد جديد في الحرب
باوكرانيا قد يصل مداه الى العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو
بعض الفاصل
تقرير يرصد
ضد المهاجرين الافارقه واجبارهم على
القتال لصالحهم بالقوه
[موسيقى]
لم تبدا الاحداث في منطقتنا حتى يومنا هذا
واليوم قبل ان يستريح العالم بعد جائعه
طالت البشريه
جديده ولكن هذه المره على مستوى العالمي
كم هائل من الاحداث والمعلومات يتدفق كل
يوم اخبار حروب وتداعيات سياسيه واقتصاديه
اصبح ما بين سطور اكثر من السطوح
ابعاد جديده تستدعي اسلوبا جديدا وتحليلا
لعالم يبدو اكثر تسارعا كل يوم
البعد الاخر مع منتخب
السبت 11:30 على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اربط هو الاحزمه واسترخو هذه رحله الى
عالم اخر سنمزج فيه الافتراضي والمعزز
كلمات معقده صحيح دعيني يوفر عليك الوقت
تعالوا معي
ومختلف جدا
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره كامله
على شاشه العربيه
اهلا بكم من جديد تقرير جديد يلقي الضوء
على انتهاء الحوت ضد المهاجرين الافارقه
وكيف يقومون باجبارهم على قتال الشعب
اليمني تحت التهديد
السلوك الحوثيين
القادمه من افريقيا الى جحيم
هربوا مما هو مر الى ما هو امر
مهاجرون من منطقه القرن الافريقي من
اثيوبيا والصومال قطعوا مضيق باب المندب
الى اليمن وكلهم امل في ان يجد الامان
لكنهم لم يواجهوا غير القسوه والغدر
من المهاج
الحوثي في الحرب لقتل اليمن واذا رفضوا
تلقوا اشد العقوبه
ما نشتيش قاتل اذا اشتري قاتل نحنا
ببلادنا من زمان
وطلبنا احنا اخواننا اليمنيين الامان وطلب
الغماء
[موسيقى]
بل هي اقرب لممارسه النازين الشرعيه
المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه للامم
المتحده سجلت وصول اكثر من 73 الف مهاجرين
افريقي الى اليمن خلال العام الماضي ياتون
الى اليمن ليتمكنوا من تقديم طلبات الهجره
او اللجوء من خلال السفارات الاجنبيه
والمنظمات الانسانيه
لكنهم لا يجدون الاضطهاد والعنف والتجنيد
القصري من قبل ميليشيات الحوثي العربيه
قال المحامي الشخصيه للرئيس الامريكي
جوبيد بابا حقيقي وزاره العدل العصر على
36 اضافيه خلال عمليه تفتيش في منزل بيض
في والميتون في ولايه دلول
في بيان رسمي انه خلال عمليه البحث التي
استغرقت قرابه اثنتي عشره ساعه استحوذت
وزاره العدل على المواد التي اعتبرتها ضمن
نطاق تحقيقها بما في ذلك ست وثائق سريه
تعود للفتره التي كان يشغل فيها بيضا
منصبه
وفي سياقه متصل بشره صحيفه تقريبا كشفت
فيه ان رئيسه موظفي البيت الابيض دوران
كلين قد يتناحا قريبا تزامنا مع التحقيق
في وثائق بايدينا سريه الصحيفه وصفت
الاستقاله المرتقبه بانها اهم تغيير في
اداره الرئيس الامريكي منذ ان تولى منصبه
قبل عامين
بيت الابيض السريه
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشفت ان مغادره ارون
كلين قد تاتي بعد خطاب بيض المقرر في
السابع من فبراير
الصحيفه وصفت الاستقاله المرتقبه بانها
اهم تغيير في اداره بيض منذ توليه الرئاسه
قبل عامين
قالوا ان البحث جار عن بديل ومن المحتمل
ان يستمر كلين لفتره انتقاليه
تاتي المغادره ايضا في وقت يواجه البيت
الابيض مجموعه واسعه من التهديدات
السياسيه والقانونيه
اشغل موقع 1945 الامريكيه الاستمراريه
تاثير ترامب داخل الحياه السياسيه في
الولايات المتحده في ذلك الى عده اسباب
[موسيقى]
قال المباص الامريكيه الخاص لمحاربه داعش
سفير جيمس جفري في مقابله مع العربيه ان
واشنطن تعمل على منع داعش من الانتشار
مجددا في المنطقه والعراق
الاسرائيليه اجتماعها الاسبوعيه
من حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه الاجتماعيه
عشرات الالاف يهدفون ديمقراطيه
ويتظاهرون مجددا من هنا من وسط شوارع
مدينه تل ابيب ضد خطه الحكومه برئاسه
باليمينه ياهو لتنفيذ التغييرات جذريه في
القضاء والتي من شانها ان تحدها من سلطات
محكمه العدل العليا
مظاهره ستكون فقط البدايه لسلسله مظاهرات
حسب تعبير احدى المنظمات المسؤوله عن
تنظيمها في ظل تخوف الحكومه من تحول
المظاهرات الى لسه مات داخليه اكبر واصيان
مدنيا محتمل لا نقول غاصي من تل ابيب
العربيه
عن حقوق الانسان في ايران نرجس محمدي
تقريرا عن العنبر العام للنساء بسجن ايفين
في طهران محمديه موجوده حاليا في السجن
61 امراه في السجن وكشفت في تقرير
من الوصول الى خدمات العلاج مما يعكس شده
القمع سجينات من قبل النظام الايراني
جسيم لحقوق الانسان صحيه
طالبه بوركينا فاسو القوات الفرنسيه
بمغادره اراضيها في غضون
وكاله الانباء الوطنيه
فيلم ده اختار حزب الله
في البرلمان على هذا المنصب اجراء شكليا
الى حد كبير وعقب اختياره
لرئاسه الوزراء
الهاتف مع رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبيه شهاده
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بسحب القوات
الارتريه من شمال اثيوبيا قال المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه الخارجيه يترحبت
بهذا التطور شيراتون الى انها خطوه اساسيه
لتامين سلام المستدام في شمال افريقيا كما
حتى تخرج الامريكيه على وصول مراقبه حقوق
الانسان الدولي
خطاب النشره تذكيرهم في ابرز العرب
العربيه ترصد المعارك المحتدمه بين
الجيشين الروسي والوكراني في مارينا
بمقاطعه دونات
تقرير الحقوقي صادم يكشف اوضاع النساء
المعتقلات الايرانيات في سجن ايفيل حب
سنين انفرادي وحرمان من الدواء
والكشف عن وثائق سريه جديده في منزل تعود
لفتره عضويته بمجلس الشيوخ وتوليه منصبنا
برايس
[موسيقى]